al caer la noche la ira se desata desde
las ventanas de los apartamentos
desafiar al régimen en los confines del
hogar es una de las únicas opciones que
les quedan a los manifestantes sigue
siendo un delito punible pero no tan
arriesgado como reunirse en las calles
este invierno debido a la feroz
represión las manifestaciones son cada
vez menos frecuentes Incluso en la
universidad de Teherán antaño lugar
clave de la oposición al régimen en
cinco meses ongs han contabilizado unas
20.000 detenciones y más de 500 Muertos
pero la rabia sigue siendo más fuerte
que el miedo como demuestra esta
manifestante que fue detenida el pasado
octubre y posteriormente liberada está
preparadora física ha denunciado sus
torturas la han condenado a 11 meses de
cárcel y 85 latigazos Pero eso no le
impide hablar
nunca abandonaré el objetivo de nuestro
movimiento mujer vida libertad
muchos prometen reanudar pronto las
protestas ante la falta de más libertad
nuestro movimiento es imparable porque
nuestra generación no puede
aceptar que están pasando como la falta
de libertad de Derechos Humanos Vamos a
continuar Pero cómo Exactamente Bueno
quitándome el y ya
figuras de la oposición en el exilio han
anunciado el inicio de negociaciones
para una posible Alianza entre ellos
tres apaglavi hijo del chairani El Rey
derrocado en 1979 su nombre evoca el
pasado imperialista del país pero muchos
verían en su regreso a Irán una solución
para construir un futuro más democrático